well listening to that I hope as the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves who
joins me now good evening to you um look
well labor has always called for the
reversal of the 45p uh policy you must
be applauding the government tonight
well of course it's welcome that they've
reversed this but so much damage has
already been done mark because what we
saw when the chancellor uh stood up to
give his so-called mini budget and in
the days afterwards was huge volatility
in financial markets and a big spike in
the costs of government borrowing but
also in the borrowing costs for ordinary
families particularly through mortgages
and anybody who is coming to the end of
a fixed rate mortgage deal or trying to
get on the housing ladder for the first
time it is finding that those costs are
going up and up in some cases hundreds
of pounds a month and this is a crisis
that was created in Downing Street but
it is being a price being paid by
ordinary Working Families the length and
breadth of this country do you think you
should be sacked for this financial
Fiasco as you put it that he's caused
well cozy cartoon is now the third
conservative Chancellor in this year I I
don't think we need another conservative
Chancellor I think we need a labor
government and increasingly the labor
party are rightly seen as the party both
of fiscal responsibility and of social
justice I've been very clear that there
will be nothing in the next Labor
Manifesto that isn't fully funded and
fully costed a huge difference from what
we see from this conservative government
right so if it was your u-turn on your
first budget or mini budget that ended
like this would you expect to be set
well I would expect that working with
Kia stalma that we would deliver a
budget based on the people's priorities
and and that is not tax cuts for the
wealthiest people in this country
millions of people are struggling with
the rising cost of living energy bills
of food prices now higher mortgage rates
as well and the chancellors trickle down
economics just does not speak to the
concerns of families businesses and
pensioners around the country and it's
not just the 45p rate it's the new rules
on Bankers bonuses it is the
prioritization of tax cuts for the
biggest businesses it's the changes on
on stamp Duty a whole range of things
unfunded tax cuts paid in the end by my
constituents in Leeds West through
higher borrowing by government and
higher mortgage rates for families well
talking of borrowing I mean labor says
it's all about credibility but you have
only what a year or so couple of years
to persuade the public that you can be
trusted with the economy
well before I became a member of
parliament I worked at the bank of
England for many years I I and I think
the Labor's respect for Economic
Institutions whether that's the bank of
England the treasury the office for
Budget responsibility does give us a
credibility that frankly this government
has lost credibility is hard won but
easily lost and this government is
losing credibility both in financial
markets which is really important when
it comes to inflation and borrowing
costs but it's also losing credibility
with the British people who are sick and
tired of broken promises about economic
growth with support for the cost of
living living standards have got worse
Public Services have got worse and our
public finances are in tatters that is a
result of 12 Years of conservative
government but you'll be borrowing as
well I mean on energy support you're now
committing to support householders until
I think 2024 same as a government is
that right
um yes so the difference between you
know I know what you're going to say the
windfall tax but your original spending
was 29 9 billion and now presumably it's
going to be what the government is
expecting which is over 100 billion
where will I mean where will that be
financed from other than than a lot of
borrowing
well there are tens of billions of
pounds that the government is leaving on
the table in the what could be raised in
Windfall tags on the huge profits the
energy companies are making the
government by leaving all that money on
the table is just adding to borrowing
costs and adding to government debt it
doesn't have to be that way if we got
our fair share from the energy Giants
who on the back of Putin's illegal
invasion of Ukraine are making huge
amounts of money then we wouldn't have
to stack so much on the the nation's
credit card but that's why it's the
responsible thing to do well the
windfall sorry to interrupt you the
windfall tax is only going to be a small
part isn't it
um of the of the borrowing you're going
to require you've also got your
commitments on green energy which work
out according to one Economist I was
reading today 200 billion over the next
eight years by 2030.
well let me say a couple of things on
that first of all of course we've got to
help people through the cost of living
crisis and that's why I've been saying
since well for months now that the
government need to do more to help
people with Rising energy bills that is
not what financial markets have a
problem with what financial markets have
a problem with is unfunded tax cuts that
last for years after the cost of living
crisis hopefully goes away that is why
financial markets reacted not to the
energy package but to the unfunded scale
of tax giveaways at the mini budget a
week and a half ago and the other thing
on the the green Prosperity plan
everybody knows that there's a world of
difference between investing in things
that can boost our long-term
productivity and growth rate by creating
jobs and ensuring that Britain can be
global leaders world leaders in the
industries of the future from hydrogen
to carbon capture and storage to
electric vehicles very different from
unfunded tax giveaways and they will be
Investments that the British people
would have a stake in and would get a
return on that investment growth from
all communities in our country rather
than the failed trickle-down economics
of this Tory government all right Rachel
Ruiz we've got to leave it there thank
you so much thank you thank you